As you dream up your ideas, it is
important to be passionate about them.
It is never a good idea to create
a startup just because you want to
create a startup.
Create a startup because you
want to solve a problem that
keeps you up at night.
Successful companies start
from a good idea and
a good idea might be
one of these things.
Solve a novel problem.
Google did that with search.
Extend the current solution.
Udacity does that by providing
an affordable on-demand
technical education for jobs.
Disrupt an industry.
Uber provides an easier
way to share a ride.
In the next video,
Chris is going to share types of idea
that might help you
come up with your idea.